I am a Swifty I'm a Swifty I'm a Swifty
I am a Swifty I am a Swifty I am a
Swifty I'm a
[Music]
Swifty okay real quick why are you all
swifties hi I'm Kate um I'm a Swifty
because in 2007 my dad called me into
the room to see Country Music Television
and she was doing tear jobs on my guitar
and he was like you should like her
she's good and that's how it started
okay I'm not that OG but uh I was
honestly a hater for a little bit you
know hearing on the radio and stuff but
then I converted when I met my
girlfriend and she was like uh it's been
a year it's been like almost year and a
half now she was like showing me all the
songs in the car and I was like this
sucks but then one day speaking now
Taylor's version came out and I went to
go buy it for and I was surrounded by
swifties like us and I just had great
conversation waiting for the CDs to come
out and I've I've been a fan ever since
okay when I said I was a hater I was
pretty glad to have said that because it
made everyone a little scary scared of
me I think it kind of built my trust
with the other cast members I became a
fan in 2006 um basically first heard uh
Mary song about the album Amazing
Fearless
obsessed and yeah she's just been like
every chapter of her life I've grown
with her I've related to her hi um big
Swifty I've been a Swifty since Taylor
Swift by Taylor Swift it was like big at
my elementary school michaa calling her
first album Taylor Swift by Taylor Swift
made me more suspicious of her because a
lot of swifties refer to it as debut
it's been lovely growing up with her I
think she is like the best lyricism of
our time and I think she's great I also
kind of got around to her whenever Tor
Swift came out I was like a kid I grew
up in Kentucky so her country music was
like everywhere and then you know
growing up queer I had to like hide that
part of myself for a really long time so
I kind of missed out on like a lot of
stuff that I would have loved to have
heard so I'm kind of getting back into
it so I've been a Swifty since I was 4
years old when debut came out my mom
bought the CD after seeing her perform
she would just play that CD in the car
all the time and it's like been kind of
a bonding thing between my mom and I I
just really look up to her as a person
and I kind of grew up with her as like a
big role model figure in my life I was
suspicious of lanaa just because there
was so much Taylor Swift going on with
like bracelets from all the I was like I
don't know if this is like she borrowed
these from a friend or not I'm an OG fan
like Tim mgra time um I hated country
music and then I had a roommate that
would only play it in the car and then
Taylor came out so I was already like
ready for it cuz I was starting to like
country music and yeah yeah what is your
guys's favorite like part of Taylor
Swift concerts like your favorite chant
or your favorite kind of little bit that
we do oh one two three let's go I
was going to say that okay she did like
the go-to so I was like okay I was
expect I was hoping to hear something
that would be a little bit more of what
a fan would know I also really like the
um where you going Taylor I thought that
was so funny whenever I heard the first
you forgive you forget but you never let
it I love bad blood guys I'm going be
honest I don't have one I mean I saw the
I saw the movie but I've never been to a
concert yeah we were all talking about
what we like about Taylor Swift but is
there anything that we like don't really
like whether it's like controversy or
just like things in general I guess for
me like I don't think there's a way to
be an ethical billionaire so I hope that
she's able to donate money or spread the
love to go back to a millionaire shees I
was actually going to bring that up I
100% agree because like she did work for
it to be fair she earned what she has
she's killing it and she's putting it
back into the community like for LGBT
and people of color and like speaking
out politically about like all these
things yeah and how many people she got
to vote exact yeah exactly and all that
money she gave back to like her truck
drivers exactly so ni I feel like all
the criticisms that people have of her
are things that are just kind of the
music industry in general like a private
jet thing every rich person is taking a
private jet everywhere yeah can you
imagine her on a commercial plane no
absolutely not I think she also rents
out her jet for like a bunch of people
there's a lot of misinformation that
gets spread where it's like she flew
like 200 times in like a few months it's
just not true there's like other people
on the
list drunk in the back of the car and I
C like a baby coming home from the cut
like this video for
[Music]
Taylor I thought that he was basically
that his girlfriend was the fan and that
he's just the guy that's forced to
listen to it she looks like what you
would imagine a Swifty to look like I
think Michaela just wasn't giving enough
she was really more
Reserve
Michaela I think I just I didn't really
talk very much I don't even think I
answered my own question okay quick
round what's her birthday December 13th
199 okay what's her mom's name Andrea
dad's name Scott brother's name
Austin cat's name
no Benjamin Button what's her go-to
cocktail like whiskey no idea po coke
with Orin I'm really torn because it was
great that he was doing a lot of the
trivia but also there were a lot of
things you could look up on Google and
practice and study she eats her chicken
fingers with ketchup and sometimes may
that's what I learned from the NFL these
are all such crazy like things to know I
haven't been in it that long to know all
these like strange things how many
toenails did she lose last year what was
her job on the Christmas Tree FM that
she would grow up on taking off the um
to sex yes yes this is
crazy deep okay these are all like
Google B questions like what are some
more things that how about so like
Cardigans like let's name albums that
have a cardigan the reputation one with
the snake in the Stars reputation
sweater doesn't exist oh the sweater the
C does what mean then oh no oh yeah I
don't think there's a cardigan for I'm
mistaking it like the the folklore and
the holiday ones have stars and must
have been that okay so I had an idea for
a little like lyric challenge so I am
going to say a lyric and then go down
the line and just say like the next line
in the song if you don't know it just
we'll go to the next person um okay time
won't fly it's like I'm Paralyzed by
it i' like to be my old self again but
I'm still trying to find it I'm not
supposed to after plaid shirt days and
something you make me your own and
something yeah and what and what it's
been a minute now you m like my things
and I walk home alone yes okay that's
interesting the lyric challenge shows
how challenging this is I flubbed a
lyric and I love all too well the
10minute version did you like the change
that she made to better than revenge
I mean I do cuz like girl supporting
girls
sure like the Nostalgia of that
time we didn't know the lyrics to All
Too Well
that is
unforgivable it's so easy to say my
girlfriend got me into it and it's only
been I feel like he said a
year and the person eliminated in this
round is
Charlie Taylor download the nectar app I
want to see how compatible we are sorry
Taylor can't come to the phone right
now let's talk about Travis Kelce what
do we think yes love him I'm kind of
like the elephant in the room we're in a
football jersey here I think it's great
that she's bringing like a lot of women
viewers to the NFL I think it's kind of
silly like people criticizing like
camera angles panning to her and stuff
like that at the game she has no control
over that exactly the comment at the
Golden Globes with joy big difference
between the Golden Globes and the NFL on
the Golden Globes we have fewer camera
shots of Taylor Swift I swear there's
just where to go to that was out of
pocket I'm glad that she didn't like
laugh off like just s at what point are
people going to realize it's not a good
idea to make fun of Taylor Swift like
that like I don't know I think that
they're always going to I it's been like
no what she does not since the beginning
but like since she started dating even
when she kept her relationship private
like with Joe people criticized her for
doing that well there's that quote that
she has it's like men are strategic
women are calculated a man does
something it's strategic a woman does
the same thing it's calculated a man is
allowed to react
a woman can only overreact is there
anyone you guys are like if anything
like I am a Little Susy just because
you're a newer fan I get I I feel like I
fit the image of not being a Taylor talk
a little bit about like how your
girlfriend like got you uh not only like
being a simp but also just like uh kind
of like actually listening to the music
like you hear like all the Silly Songs
in the radios that give people the
interpretation that all her music is
about like breakups and stuff like that
but like actually listening to like some
songs like your favorite songs I was
going to say my favorite song is
Superman
which yeah we were listening to speak
now after she bought it and she was like
this song is like like not many people
like it and I was listening to it I was
like dude this song is incredible what
are you talking about like I like comic
books and all that stuff what's your
favorite Bridge oh my God I was going to
ask that no clue no clue no clue dude um
elicit Affairs don't come don't call a
baby just on my floor just like this
with like the wind like
yeah all
right
[Music]
we have a tie uhoh the tie is between
Orin and
cristelle okay my case is um it doesn't
matter what you're wearing or what you
look like I love her when her albums
come out like at 9:00 p.m. for us don't
text me don't call me I have to be alone
I have to like experience it I have to
listen to it at least twice I don't know
I just I'm too old to make friendship
bracelets but I think it's so cute I if
I were younger I would well I don't
think that their age there's a limit to
it whatsoever um I'm dressing like this
I'm 35 like and I'm a grown man and I'm
still wearing friendship bracelet and
bedazzled this shoes sash shirt
everything
like Oren just kind of started talking
about everything he was wearing and he
could have just borrowed his outfit from
one of his friends who's a
Swifty
and the person eliminated this round is
Orin I'm not sure what happened in the
third round as to why they started to
think that I was the mole I've answered
every question I've kept the
conversation going I'm like laughing
with them singing with them like aside
from them saying like my outfit seem
costumi and for show which it is for
show
but if everyone feels confident that you
already caught the mole you can end the
game now but if the majority has doubts
the game will continue raise your hand
if you want to continue playing the game
in three two
one the game has ended
nice if the lights turn green that means
you have voted out the mole and you win
if the lights turn red that means the
mole is still in the box and you
lose
in
three
[Music]
1's go let's go God Swifty is no other
Swifty that's all I have to say will the
mole step forward in
three
two
one that's I'll never forgive her for
that
sweater someone must have made it yeah
was she wearing it or no it was like I
Google it yeah so reputation and lover
people have made their own but they
don't actually exist well I got got no
okay so I find her music fine I am not a
Swifty at all I'm a punk I'm an
anarchist and I go by those values and
her values do not match up with mine at
all so I am not into pop whatsoever I
have always been into punk music from
the day that I was born and I will
continue to be this is what I'm like in
real life I don't even go by Charlie I
go by dogf face so you know if I showed
up looking like this how I usually do it
would be um pretty obvious I don't
really like in her music video for like
um you need to calm down the whole queer
thing a lot of people who are also gay
are like she's an ally blah blah blah
and yes she did speak about the trans
issue but one of the things that she
also does is not really speak on
anything else that queer people maybe go
through um specifically right now she
has chosen not to speak about Palestine
any celebrity who is not currently
talking about it especially someone with
so much influence and power need to take
a stand for Palestine because otherwise
you are complicit 100% And I do not like
that if she stood up and said hey guys
maybe genocide is bad everybody would be
like hey you know what you're right it
is bad swifties unite that kind of thing
that's the bare minimum but she could
also be like supporting like quietly
like maybe she's she shouldn't do that I
don't agree with that okay when they
were uh going on about Taylor Swift I
felt a little rage inside um do you have
to say he was fair where he was saying
he didn't hate Taylor Swift as a person
he was just hating the choices because I
think you're allowed to like someone or
not like someone based on choices and
just not them generally as a person I
was going to say if anybody has like a
disagreement I would love to know sure I
don't have a disagreement I just think
like that's totally valid if you feel
that way about every celebrity who's not
speaking out on it it's not just like
I'm mad that Taylor Swift's not doing it
so I think I can be a fan of her and
still like criticism abely if you had
like no complaints that would be an
issue but I'm totally fine with like
hardcore pedal Toth metal Swift fans who
are also like hey this is bad I I can
appreciate his passion in Palestine and
the Gaza Strip uh and I'm glad that he's
passionate about that it's just it's
kind of a topic not to be put in a box
with a bunch of Swift fans not they
we're not concerned but you know we
we're kind of more focused on Taylor
Swift being uplifting and being a role
model and letting people know that their
voices can be heard versus you know
having her solve all of the world's
problems global warming and War in the
Gaza Strip I did listen to all of her
albums um folkore fine some of the songs
from 1989 were good I liked the song I
can't remember the name of the really
popular one Shake It Off NOP did not
like
that